leur répond également à la partie celui
ci a d'ailleurs déclaré qu'il irait
jusqu'au bout dans les câbles au liban
il ya dix jours que ça dure
il ne quitte pas les abris l'année
dernière a été la plus de 4000 au but
l'addition aurait dû chrétiens ce matin
profitant d'une trêve ils sont sortis
pour constater les dégâts
s'approvisionner aucune solution
le suicidaire at il lancé
ban est dans les canons sont tournés
vers ce petit carré rose sur la carte le
réduit chrétiens guerre de libération
contre l'occupation
ce dernier bat pas la véritable de
certains leaders chrétiens qui dit ne
plus vouloir entendre parler de réformes
l'élection présidentielle quand le plus
proche arrachant leur sol manoeuvre de
diversion capitaine est libanais